i mean this is exactly what uh open ai
and deep uh demine at google or uh
i don't know if you've seen
but there's something called
reinforcement learning in artificial
intelligence where
you have like they've done it for like
sumo wrestling you have you have like
you have these two stick figures that
don't even know how to get up at first
and they figure out how to stand on
their two feet
and then they figure out how to push the
other person off of the the pedestal
wait so
but what about like uh when you look at
the the boston dynamics sometimes they
have trouble with like jumping and
balancing into other stuff so are they
are they doing that same program or no
no no no this different the
everything boston dynamics is doing
is hard-coded so it's not um
it's not learning the
all the sophisticated movements and
strategies like high-level strategies
and movement that's all
something that boston dynamics does not
do and if it does it like the parkour
stuff that's all hard coded in oh
people like project and think like
these robots have like discovered
like how to move in sophisticated ways
they haven't well that's what when you
and john were talking about the the
grappling robot yeah i mean the one
thing i was i was obsessing about in my
head is that
with the chest right if a chess piece
moves right uh the horse can move like
an l right
it can only move like an l it doesn't
matter if it moves at two meters per
second or seven meters per second it can
only it can only move there right
whereas like a single leg i can shoot a
single leg with many different
velocities
i can shoot at different angles i can
shoot with different amounts of force
right i can shoot my my head up versus
my head i mean right all these things
are going to matter if we're talking
about a human being defending the single
leg all of those things are going to
matter and and that's where human beings
are
who wrestle are calculating those things
subconsciously they're obviously not
consciously calculating in your head oh
the the force is coming at me at this so
i need to do that right there's doing it
but yeah the the thing is so you would
absolutely if you're doing a robot that
you're wrestling you're going to have to
constrain the speed at which it moves
and the power that it's able to uh
deliver so that presumably
that'll be the limitation so then it'll
be just the same exact way as a human
but then but
even so if we go human max force or
jordan bros double max force right
that's the highest as highest we get
then we go down from there um
even even with even within that it's
like sometimes i can choose things like
with a maximum force of i don't know
we'll just say we'll say 20. this is a
number right
i don't know i shoot at 20 because i
feel sometimes i shoot at 15. sometimes
you shoot it at 12 right because you you
feel something in your opponent that
makes you do it differently so they
would have to learn how and then you
know all these different things and
sometimes maybe i clamp a little harder
so the the robot would have to learn all
these different incoming inputs to the
system and then create this reaction oh
no no 100 so this would be all
continuous like yeah so unlike chess it
would not it's just chess is discrete
there's it's uh one and then you move
it's it's a very specific set of moves
now here you would those are all
variables you control and they're
continuous variables so the speed the
force there's actuators so there's all
these joints right yeah you can move i
mean it's just an optimization problem
it's kind of fast it's fascinating so
i've been fascinated thinking about it
since you guys talked about it with i it
was a long time ago i listened to it
probably three three to four weeks ago
i've kind of been like obsessing about
it ever since
yeah it just changes
when um
so unlike boxing for example or striking
it you know once you grab a hold of
somebody
it changes you're now one body
right so yeah it's very complicated it's
not just shooting a a double leg without
like maybe doing like
like faking a double leg and then
shooting the double leg that's very
doable with robotics but then like
doing a clinch and from there
doing like a russian tie like that
that's uh i think that's way harder than
people realize in terms of how many
things are involved like the force of
the grip the leverage you're providing
with all the different parts of the
shoulder and the arm and the torso the
twist how much of your weight are you
allocating like leaning on the other
person like taking weight off of one of
your legs and the other leg all of that
i think
that's the really interesting thing
about humans is we're able to do all of
this calculation subconsciously yeah
subconsciously yeah and that's why we
think about since we it's like
how many things even these high school
athletes who are like getting medium
good are subconsciously thinking about
all the time or not even not even
thinking about reacting to
um but then even like for me i'm you
know i'm a few orders of meg do better
than somebody's kid that player and so
when i when i go like super hard it's
like
i can feel their weight moving the wrong
direction and so for me to off balance
them or trip them or whatever it's kind
of easy sometimes you know because
they're not feeling it
the right way right or their timing
timing's just a little bit off or the
way they're grabbing the hip maybe they
should be up a little higher right these
really small things
um
yeah i think that's all easy to take
advantage of for a robot it's just
there's so many things
the the big problem is ethically
i don't know how many people are willing
to train with a robot because
you're gonna get hurt well can you make
a robot change a robot or no yes but
then it's expensive
so because
what's the padding on that thing i know
but that but then it's not
you know
it it's
then
you're not capturing the full why can't
you put like some rubber coating on them
right you know something for that effect
you could i mean you could yeah you
could i mean you're talking about robots
that are
these are humanoid robots so
we're talking about 500 000 million
robots
so you would have to be motivated
spend a lot of money to spend a lot of
money because you have to have them
wrestle
for like
a lot
to get better you have to get better
yeah and then
the the open question is
how
long does it take to get good enough to
beat a human
uh
i don't i don't think i don't think we
understand i don't know i don't think
you understand
how hard wrestling is yeah like is it a
really hard problem like what's harder
chess or wrestling
by far not even close that's yeah that's
the sense
so because there's an infinite amount of
moves right uh and possibilities so once
i shoot the single leg now you have
x amount of choices once you make your
choice now i have a choice x amount of
choices no i now you have x amount
choices on the defense and we can just
keep going back and forth right and this
number becomes
yeah but the same happens with chess
correct but then in wrestling you have
to make these
movements in very very instantaneously
right because i should say like i'm not
going to wait and say what's your
defense yeah right he's being
instantially and then also again based
on the force and the vectors and and the
angles
you have to calculate that and adjust so
really you know if you're saying well i
can shoot a single like it's not like
moving it's not one move right it's if
you want to talk about different forces
and stuff it could be hundreds or
thousands of different moves based on
how hard i shoot it the angle the
direction all of those things yeah but
wait a minute so robots can do this kind
of stuff really fast you what i
people probably know the physiology of
this but it's the the reaction speed for
a human is maybe 100 milliseconds
something like that i don't know from
sensation to to
like from
the the signal traveling up your brain
and down i don't know what that number
is but uh robots certainly could do it
way faster it you would actually have to
like constrain the speed
well so the robot's already killing the
chess people
right so yeah theoretically they could
eventually beat wrestlers but you asked
what was hard wrestling chess
yeah i think wrestling is because of the
time component in it and then the and
and the physicality of
you know is it this force or that force
you know because if if i'm going to say
say we're in a seat belt side by side
right a wrestling seatbelt nothing too
based on the pressure you're giving me i
might do a bunch of different things
right and so like to an untrained eye
they might both look like the same thing
from you to a trained feel it's like
well in one case it's really evident i
should go this way in other cases i
should go that way so the other thing to
consider just like with chess the ai
systems
so human versus human play a certain way
together they actually haven't
considered a really large number of
strategies
that ai systems discover so one
possibility with the robot they'll
discover certain ties and certain
takedowns what i'm saying
that like will dominate no matter what
the human does you think that so you
think there's that so this i mean this
time the wrestling's so fun is there's
even after 80 90 years there's this
continuous evolution yeah so you can do
some like low single type thing like
john smith type of situation well look
at downbot go behind is something that
has really i would say really in the
last five-ish years has really been
evolved what's it go behind down bought
go behind so when you're sh well they
just head inside or head outside matters
but there's one for both you shoot at me
essentially i take my leg like boom and
then so that was kind of in existence
when i was in college right you down
block them and you stop but usually you
hit on this side of their head right and
now immediately as you should i attack
that shoulder and then i start hitting a
go behind on you right and so like that
in its current incarnation
it absolutely wasn't when i was in
college i would say it probably became
popular
five to seven years ago so yeah there's
these big things that are happening
and now now i really want a robot
because i want to be ahead of the game i
want to know
what i'm missing i mean one interesting
thing you have with alpha zero that
plays chess
is um
it sacrifices pieces much more than
humans do so give you a piece and not
only does it give you a piece it will
wait a bunch of moves before it makes
you pay
so because it knows that that's better
for the long term long term so like
humans rarely sacrifice without
getting the piece back like two or three
moves after uh alpha zero can wait like
five moves
so
so basically you'll have your potential
with wrestling you might have a
a robot that like puts itself in bad
positions but in a certain kind of way
then
that will actually where's the opponent
in to trap
exactly what my style's based on
you basically narrow one one thing to do
is you narrow the set of choices you put
yourself in a bad position but it
narrows a set of choices for them
because they're not used to it yeah
they're not used to it and and then you
you drag them into uh into your
yeah so but there's also
the problem is there's mechanical issues
like it's actually just difficult to
build robots that uh are able to sense
because we have sensation throughout our
body yeah it's just difficult to build
that kind of robot it's expensive you
start talking about multi multi-million
dollars and then people start asking you
questions why did you invest all this
money
duh hello
it could be a better investment
you